thrilled to have him here on the Rich
Eisen show how are you Chad I'm doing
great thanks for having it I am
congratulations is that an appropriate
way to say it or do you tell me how do
you that no yeah that's that's
appropriate you know I think it's far
from over but no you know it was a good
good first step for sure well I mean how
long were you thinking in that moment um
I wasn't thinking about it that wall
honestly you know I think it hit me
Monday morning when I woke up and and
that's kind of how I wanted to approach
how I wanted to put that whole day you
know I want to do it I wanted that whole
day to do your special as it could be
without you know making it more than
what it was might be or maybe not having
it be as special as it could have been
so for whatever was worth I wanted it to
be exactly that and I didn't want to
read too much into it until it got to
that day well I mean were you thinking
about it I guess during chemotherapy the
fact that you were I mean what were you
fixing on to get yourself through that
experience Chad um I wasn't thinking
about baseball at all to tell you the
truth and be completely honest with you
of it was you know winging more phil on
my faith in my family and my daughter
that had just been born i think he is
there was more of getting through each
day and being able to go home into my
family my wife and my daughter how old
is your daughter she's four months now
and honestly Jedi how did you take the
diagnosis with a wife at home and a
newborn care I mean with a so I would've
diagnosis hit when I would imagine I
guess your wife was pregnant
Jen oh yeah yep yeah uh it was tough
honestly you know there was a lot of
questions we had one of the more
important ones being was the chemo
therapy going to affect how I was going
to be able to be a father and you know
was I going to be able to be with my
wife in the hospital when she was giving
birth was I going to be able to hold my
daughter because
makino drug and and so we have a lot of
questions more so on my expand my side
from Christy but no you know something
that we we just have to get through Chad
Bettis here on the Rich Eisen show again
a couple of days after seven scoreless
against the Braves although the way that
start started Chad I mean that was
interesting walk us through that process
for those that might not have seen the
way that your your start started no yeah
so hopefully interesting he says at
least I think it was probably from one
of the highest highs that I've ever been
in to oh crap what's pulling on I'm
about to end up 1-nothing first batter
of the game so throw the pitch hits a
pretty well hit line drive to our left
fielder Laura that was shallow he's
running in sprinting in hard took a dive
at it slipped under his glove rolled all
the way to the wall inciarte is rounding
third I'm running back busting my butt
as fast as I can to get behind home
plate to you know cover and see the real
eight will come in from story and we now
on that I was just like a huge roller
coaster to just you know really
stressful of of how that game was going
to be for me so you couldn't even score
that one at home Chad right oh no not at
all I mean that that is a that is a hell
of a triple and a put out at home plate
like through the shortstop to start your
start to keep it scoreless and then and
then as you're going you're going
through it did you see some of the kids
in the stands holding up signs saying
that they were cancer survivors yeah I
saw I actually saw some of them when I
was walking at I'm not necessarily
during the game but when my last my last
bullpen pitch open to open that door
from the bullpen to walk into the
dugouts to start the game that's kind of
when everything really hit me
and you know I was trying to hold back
sincere
yeah because I mean I can imagine you
can't be blamed for focusing on self
wife newborn daughter to get to that
mound but then when you get on the mound
and you realize how inspirational you
are to others I mean that that that had
to be pretty damn heavy
Chad oh yeah no for sure you know I mean
I didn't like I said I didn't know what
I was going to look like either and so
to open that bullpen door and she little
kid holding up signs in there cancer
survivors or there fighting through
cancer and they're trying to stay as
strong if they can through it it's I
mean it
Wow you know Chad Bettis here in the
Rich Eisen show a couple more minutes
with the Rockies starter again
testicular cancer is it's gone from your
system right Chad you're cancer-free is
were chatting right right okay right and
what what did you think of when you got
to Twitter and you saw everybody from
fellow cancer survivor Jon Lester to Ben
Stiller giving you shoutouts on social
media for how you have come back and
what you did Monday no I I mean wow I
think you know it was unbelievable with
the amount of support that I've gotten
like you said from Ben Stiller John
Laster Andrew McCutchen the McCarthy and
you know I mean it goes on way beyond
just those guys too you know I mean just
random baseball fans to people that
don't even watch baseball is reaching
out to me saying how you know inspired
they are and stuff I think you know it
it goes way beyond baseball you know and
I think but at the same time that shows
kind of how tight our fraternity of
players is you know we're going against
each other each and every day battling
for that win but you know baseball aside
worshipping up
Fernan kappa you know we're in it
together what's your favorite Ben
Stiller movie Chen I like a lot of them
I think dodge balls one of the top one
not sure the Ocho you watch your
volleyball on the Oh Jones basically
what you said that's a good one that's
that's a pretty damn good one it's
pretty cool it that he that he tweeted
he tweeted with you in at you and and
and then Bud Black we couldn't help but
notice when you get back to the the
dugout your manager gave you that
handshake what was that conversation if
you wouldn't mind being a fly on the
wall there no yeah it was and when he
walked over in the seventh inning after
the seventh I got down out of that
inning I knew what he was about to say
you know hey you're done you know good
job but he didn't even have to say it
you know and I knew you know what she
was thinking the emotions that he must
have been feeling and when he shook my
hand and was like you did great you know
we're gonna hand it off the bulb in here
you couldn't have scripted it any better
and welcome back you know it was like I
I can't even I can't put into words you
know it was like a breath of fresh air
well just for the radio audience who
might not have seen it
the look on buds face pride he's proud
like he looked like a proud dad Chad
that's what it looked like and then yeah
it looked like it that hit you that hit
you right in the heart and in the gut
just that look that he was giving you is
that a fair assessment oh for sure for
sure very very much stuff hey um I can't
tell you how inspirational it was to me
and everyone else and the fact that you
are you're back and you know any line
score would have been fine but the the
the performance that you had was was
just terrific Chad and I can't wish any
more best to you and your wife what's
your wife and your daughter's name
never Lee to Christina and Everly and
you and the rest of your family
congratulations and and way to go and
thanks for calling in yeah thank you for
having me again of course and stay
healthy but and before I let you go what
what should people do for awareness for
testicular cancer what should people do
let's give people something to think
about as you hang up um you know I mean
that's kind of my whole goal here to
bring more awareness to this disease and
and I think I think what's really scary
about it is that there's not a lot of
people that know about it and and the
age that it affects is 15 35 years old
and very very common it's much more
common than people that you can expect
so you know I think for anyone that's
listening whether you have a teenage boy
or young son or a friend that might have
a son you know just get the word out you
know and it's okay to speak up and and
know that the earlier you catch this the
better your chances are going to be and
so I think that's you know I think
that's what needs to be said is you know
if you find something just go ahead and
speak up it's okay and we all know about
the Stand Up to Cancer Campaign that the
MLB folks have been deeply involved with
and obviously you're at the forefront of
it waited way to stand up Chad way to do
with you thank you look forward to the
next time we chat thanks for calling oh
you got it oh that's Chad Bettis so Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience
if you like that download or app please
just give it Sam Emory thing just delete
other apps you don't need those apps
this app the Rich Eisen show up you need
that